based on your experiences working in
female ed companies where they better
run than mail at companies you've worked
with for so i'm asked specifically
companies that you've worked with or for
were male-led companies run better or
were female let companies run better and
overwhelmingly
close to a thousand votes male-led
companies are run better only two
percent female said female lead
companies are run better now the
comments is where it got really
interesting um
so
this dude over here says two things
about kevin alera came to mind when i
saw this one as a guy who's worth
several hundred million dollars or more
he's in a position to only deal with the
top one percent of women led businesses
so
that's true um
he said they have a hundred thousand
applications for shark tank at the start
of the season they were talking about
filming season seven and of the hundred
thousand he i mean he's only got 44
companies you know that he's invested in
in the last uh nine years of doing
dragon's den and shark tank um so
not a lot of the companies getting money
i mean most of them by a very very
strong high margin get
big fat donut they get a goose egg
so that's interesting and that's a very
good point so he's only dealing with the
top percent top one percent of women led
businesses so only the best actually get
through i know there's some they push
through for fodder um because it would
make for good tv
or just some bat [ __ ] crazy sort of
pitch that'll that'll do really well you
know for the uh ratings but for the vast
majority they're only sending through
you know the best-led businesses so the
failures never make it to his doorstep
so his investments don't necessarily
represent the median or average
women-led business and two judging from
how he operates on shark tank i'd be
skeptical of if his investments are
actually women-led once he becomes an
investor
so
i'm sure he's not doing like
if you're managing 44 companies if
you're filming shark tank if you're
constantly doing television interviews
if you're buying and trading watches he
spends a lot of his time down in miami
riding his beach cruiser you know up and
down the beach sort of thing um
he's he's probably not very involved in
all of all the companies that he's
invested in uh but he probably has a
team that takes care of that for him at
this point um so whether they're
men or women i don't know but you know
he's making a valid point here uh he's
very controlling and demanding as an
investor and likes big ownership stakes
so so he most likely calls the shots
behind the scenes and the females at his
companies are most more likely just
managers for his investments at this
point
that's a valid point right um
women will typically defer to
high value strong alpha-type males so if
whoever is
leading or you know whoever's on the
board that's
helping them lead up and make decisions
you know sort of thing um
they're they're likely doing doing
a good chunk of the work whether it's a
lot of it or a little bit of it they're
doing a good chunk of the work i mean
they're offering their advice
uh clearly so
but at the same time you know they're
doing the same thing with dudes as well
so
clearly by wide margin he seems far
happier with female lead companies this
guy here says the company i work for is
a 70 year old family owned grocery chain
with about 3.5 billion in annual sales
it was ran just fine under the
leadership of the founder his name is
bob a few years ago he passed away and
left the sole ownership to his only
daughter she proceeded to slice and dice
the company to the bone
ripping the spirit of a father's legacy
to shreds she recently sold the entire
company of 200 plus california locations
to an investment group from southern
california hopefully they'll right the
ship and get it pointed in the right
direction
one of the things i've noticed about
female-led businesses
is um
female entre
okay from from the perspective of men
and women and attraction which is you
know really what pretty much everything
boils down to i think it was oscar wilde
that said something along the lines of
everything in the world's about sex
except for sex sex is about power
so one of the things i've noticed
a lot you know when it comes to female
led businesses is
they
how can i put this
i don't want to dox anybody so they they
they have a habit of getting involved
with their employees way more so
than men do in male rep run businesses
the vast majority of entrepreneurs that
i know are dudes and very few of them
get involved
you know with employees in such a way
that's risky a lot of women
almost all of them in fact now that i
think about it have at some point gotten
involved with
um an employee or employees so
interesting thing to note there and you
know some of the differences because a
lot of time guys get criticized for
um you know dipping the pen in the
company inc sort of thing
but the reality of this is that actually
you know from my personal experience you
know an observation it happens more with
women uh this guy says had female bosses
and overwhelmingly they were overbearing
and stuck to the books whereas most male
bosses were more laid back and keen to a
la lazier fair leadership style
um i'll say in my experience dealing
with female managers has been a total
nightmare deal okay so
let me say this um
when i was in the collection world uh i
don't know we had
probably six or seven hundred seats in
the office that i was in
so there was divisional managers for
each department for student loans for
sundry items for federal loans for uh
workplace safety board claims uh credit
cards and secure so there's all these
different departments so there's
probably about
12 to 15 managers um i was one of the
managers at the time when i was in the
organization and i reported directly to
the vice president so
there's there's there's all these like
upper level um you know folks that have
done the work and a small handful were
women i think two were women they were
so difficult to work with
um
everything was like
you know drama um
[Music]
so and so looked at so and so the wrong
way
it wasn't done exactly you know to
specifications you know that they
you know it set or if you talk them in a
certain way that they don't like uh
they never use terms like mansplaining
back then
that's a relatively new term but similar
to that they would what are you talking
to me like that you can't talk to me
like that
that's just how it went sometimes i mean
but some of them are real tough cookies
like you would not want to be in a
relationship with them
i couldn't imagine coming home to a to a
female entrepreneur wife or girlfriend
and just like that would that would just
for me be a version of hell
um i'll say that my experience dealing
with feeling managed has been a total
mayor however corporate america is much
better suited for women than men in my
opinion not sure but entrepreneurs he's
got a point the way that corporate
america is going right now with the
the wokeness of the inclusivity the you
know the rainbow days and all that sort
of stuff
um
it's
probably beta type men and women that
are you know leading the charge on that
for being honest i mean a guy like me i
would i mean if i was still
running my business and i had employees
and i was taking care of all that sort
of stuff right now i'm a company one and
i much prefer it this way i would you
know somebody said oh we have to change
our twitter banner to accommodate this
month or that month or whatever alphabet
soup thing was going on i'd be like no
homie don't play that game
um but the vast majority of corporate
world today you know rolls that way
uh
i did get weird weird requests from
female in
employees often uh
even like female lead you know
departments i i this one that was like
obsessed with
wearing her pajamas to work on fridays
for some reason it's just strange i was
like no we're not wearing pajamas to
work coming to work looking like we need
to work and get things done here
um this guy here says i work for a
department within the federal government
i'd say our denial region director's
denial region directors okay and
regional directors uh generals work
harder than their male counterparts but
i don't think it's all productive
okay interesting since 2018 i work with
and still am working with big tech firms
but personally speaking working in a
team about female team members is a
thousand percent better than having them
in a team based on my experience
okay that's interesting it's cutting off
the end of it here for some reason
ah that's there we go
based on my experience females can
create successful businesses or
businesses but working under them is a
nightmare for a guy who has red pill
aware yeah i've had a like i've had a
lot of private conversations with guys
now where
they actually either leave or they aim
to leave the company that they're in
because
they can't take the brow beating and
the word that i've heard a lot is abuse
so i'm just paraphrasing that um you
know from their from their boss or from
their employer in situations like that
uh just see what happened to mclaren f1
team when the daughter got in charge of
the company she had to sell it
eventually because her management wasn't
right says alex
i am working for a place that used to be
run more by men but it changed over the
years and now i think the managers and
executive are mostly women and the
biggest difference between men and women
leaders are the lack of professionalism
by the women in my opinion
um
i'll tell you what
i've i've heard from you know women
hey coops bend over so i can slap your
bum with my licorice in the office in
front of other people
uh i've never heard men talk to went
that way on
any professional level out in the open
publicly maybe privately i don't know
uh but yeah there's there's definitely
uh
a gap in professionalism here you know
this point that he's making uh the way
they handle gossiping and other messy
stuff is pretty much pretending not to
hear and see anything and if you
complain about it they seem to
manipulate you by gaslighting you in a
clever way and don't take accountability
for their actions they don't seem to
care as much as men in my opinion
and uh there's an issue where they use
the same tactics as they do so
these guys are talking about you know
there's one guy that was talking about
uh corporate one guy in i.t regional
director of government blah blah
again to o'leary's point the women that
he's investing in are running businesses
where they know them like the back of
their hands cupcakes dog clothing
electric bicycles
like things that chicks care about
um in the corporate world to some of the
points that these guys are making
yeah they'll just
it's like you know the old adage like
how long you've been working there you
know that question you asked an employee
and then and then her answer is ever
since they threatened to fire me sort of
thing um so he's making some points here
based on his experience
let's see what we got it depends on the
business women in positions of power
when it comes to construction
engineering and technology seem to have
chips on their shoulders
a lot of guys have mentioned that to me
majority of them only see these
positions due to affirmative action
hires and not from rising through ranks
which gives them confidence issues and
turns them into complete
i gotta expand this over here for some
reason it keeps cutting that off oh it
doesn't even show it to me anyway but um
yeah valid point uh just take amazon and
ebay for example amazon was led by jeff
bezos and ebay was led by meg whitman
now look at their market caps
haven't worked around a female business
but have had female managers okay
nothing too out of the ordinary except
for the suicidal cry for help when she
sent me pictures of her weapon while she
was drunk went over and talked about it
and then she
prepositioned me for sex
i'm assuming
when you set her weapon you mean her
with jizzle
are there several examples of companies
led by females eventually failing yeah
who was that chick um that got caught up
in that um
government
inquiry that blonde girl i can't
remember her name right now
yeah but she had a big number and
and flopped everything
um
i work okay here we go i've worked for a
female owners more than once and the bs
has always been through the roof my wife
works for a real estate firm owned by a
woman and only has women working there
it's a total nightmare she cannot jump
ship yet due to the real estate rules in
our state
uh crazy okay so yeah that's a good
point um if you've ever dated a check
that's a real estate agent
as i'm sure you have done at some point
you will notice that they do work mostly
with women in their office there's one
check that i dated that um
it was it was an all-female office i
think there was something like 18 and
all i heard was
becky did this and jill did that and
that [ __ ] and blah blah blah and i
can't believe and if that it's like
i don't know how they live with that
[ __ ] to be honest with you um
but o'leary's getting better returns
and
he seems happy with that
seems like they're setting more
achievable goals than dudes and that's
why it is
so there you have it hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you